hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen valentine's Day is around
the corner and you're probably all
trying to figure out what token gift
you're gonna go with crusty box of
chocolates yeah lingerie just jump
jewelry
well jewelry is never a bad idea but if
you really want to score some brownie
points and do it on the cheap then a
homemade meal with a mind-blowing
speaker is the key to Valentine's Day
success bonus points
there's a little booze involved today
I'm going to show you three easy healthy
and naturally gluten-free desserts that
will wow your sweetheart using the
ultimate celebration drink sparkling
wine and not just any sparkling wine
this is Valentine's Day after all I'm
using my favorite strawberry sparkling
called proceedeth from Chile that gets
its beautiful pink hue and berry flavor
a hundred percent naturally from
hand-picked patagonian strawberries it's
fresh feminine and super elegant perfect
for Valentine's Day dessert first up my
strawberry southern yan brulee place a
glass middle bowl over a pot of
simmering water and add two egg yolks
two tablespoons of sugar and a quarter
cup of strawberry sparkling whisk until
it's doubled in volume then serve over
fresh berries with a sprinkle of sugar
and torch it off like creme brulee
next my strawberry black pepper sorbet
mix 1/4 cup of sugar 2 cups of
strawberry sparkling and 2 tablespoons
of crushed peppercorns and stir it over
medium heat until the sugar dissolves
then strain out the peppercorns and pop
it in the blender with a quart of fresh
strawberries and 2 tablespoons of aged
balsamic churn it in your ice cream
maker for sorbet or you can just pop it
right in the freezer to make it simple
granita and finally strawberry sparkling
ice gelee before the French or jelly for
the rest of us dissolve 1/2 a cup of
sugar into a bottle of sparkling wine
with a cup of strawberries over medium
heat then strain out those strawberries
mix introduce all tablespoon and a half
of gelatin then pour the mixture into
champagne flutes pop in a few fresh
strawberries and refrigerate for a few
hours until set there you have it three
sparkling desserts me with love bubbles
and strawberries that will guarantee you
more action than that a card ever could
a big happy Valentine's Day from my
kitchen to yours for more great tips and
recipes on how to fall back in love with
food be sure to subscribe to my channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen